it has been a crazy week in america
let's find out what happened
president biden's first state of the
union speech was this week and it was
one hour long but the first 15 minutes
was just him trying to get up the
capitol steps
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry
this will forever remain the funniest
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
instantly picks me up i know i was i
wasn't having a a perfect day until i
saw that now
that's right biden's state of the union
was one hour long and this is weird
brett kavanaugh cried the whole time
[Music]
a hate woman
[Music]
i don't like that guy
according to a new poll six percent of
americans think the pandemic is
completely under control and all of them
are at dave and buster's right now
pandemica shorts right there what was in
that picture
pandemic of shorts
he doubled down on it a pandemic
i don't care if you wear a mask or not
but don't be wearing shorts
but real talk i love dave and busters
and if you think you saw me there you
did
the united states recently lifted a
week-long ban on importing avocados from
mexico and i gotta say i'm ecstatic oh
are you a big avocado fan amber huge
avocado fan so that week-long band was
really frustrating i bet you're glad
they lifted it then big time in fact i
was so excited i went to the store the
moment the band was lifted and i bought
the very first crate of avocados right
off the truck
wait you bought an entire crate of one
week old avocados you know those have a
pretty short shelf life right i'm sure
they're fine and i bought enough for
everyone here catch
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sorry wally i guess that was a little
over ripe it's okay i walked right into
that one
get out
moving on
the makers of coors light announced this
week that they will stop using plastic
rings on their six packs of beer which
is a bummer because that was by far the
tastiest part
according to cnn american tweens and
teens are embracing they them pronouns
so if you're wondering what the next
argument at your family dinner will be
about it'll be about they them
president biden held a celebration at
the white house on monday to mark black
history month when asked why so late in
the month he replied i'm on cpt
we don't
have footage of him being late to
something and saying i'm on cbt but
you you know
and he says it like
[Laughter]
he's fine he's fine he'll do and finally
astronomers recently confirmed the
existence of a planet with two sons
said the inhabitants don't come here
it's too hot
[Applause]
and that was the monologue
did you guys like it
president biden on tuesday delivered his
first state of the union address there
were lots of high points and two
extremely low points while biden was
talking about the death of his son beau
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
heckled him from the back of the room
and shortly after that bobert and
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green started chanting build the wall
but despite all the heckling from these
two insane women the president ended up
giving a solid speech solid speech the
only thing solid about baton are his
stools and even they thought his speech
was crap oh
no
margaery taylor green and lauren bobert
are you here to heckle me looks like
you're heckling yourself with that
haircut
guys guys i have a comedy show to do a
comedy show i thought this was a funeral
i wish it was mine
why are you guys even here if you hate
the show so much we don't hate anything
that's right we hate everything
okay you know what you guys are being
really disruptive if you're gonna stay
can you at least keep it down keep it
down i can't keep it down i'm going to
spew
aim for my eyes and put me out of my
misery
[Laughter]
you guys i think i'm done talking to the
both of you
build the wall build the wall build the
wall where between me and you so i don't
have to watch this show anymore hey
marjorie what's the difference between
this audience and that white stuff that
falls from the sky i don't know nothing
they're all a bunch of snowflakes
ladies please stop interrupting the show
wait what you don't have any insults for
derrick no we don't why because he's hot
and that's enough
you know what you guys are both the
worst wait what are you doing we're
turning our backs cause we don't want to
look at you
hey marjorie what's the only thing worse
than looking at amber what looking at
that audience
you can insult me but you cannot insult
my audience get out of here fine with me
these tickets were free and they still
cost too much
i think they're still laughing
i think they're still laughing they're
still laughing
lauren bobert and marjorie taylor green
everybody
don't
don't wave like that
one of those nails is going to take out
an eye
in other news astronomers have
discovered two supermassive black holes
that are on their way towards a
collision with each other that will rock
the very fabric of space and time
and to that i say
no thank you i don't want anything to do
with this piece of news yeah i don't
want to think about that at all
you see
some news gives me the blues
some news makes me feel pissed
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist
i can't get sucked through a hole in the
fabric of space and time and end up back
in the 80s jerry curl juice stains your
clothes
no no no no thank you
no
that just doesn't exist
some news makes me feel joy
some news fills me with this
cause some news is just too bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist like this a new
york man went to the hospital recently
complaining of difficulty breathing and
doctors found a tooth growing inside his
nose
absolutely not no no
worrying about getting cavities inside
your nose teeth
how am i supposed to get a toothbrush up
there no
i'm gonna pretend like that news story
doesn't exist
is that an exactly healthy approach
nothing i've ever done has ever been
healthy terry davis
that just doesn't exist
[Music]
it doesn't exist like this
a nova scotia couple's three-year-old
bulldog gave birth to a litter of eight
puppies and one of the puppies came out
green
how why
does the incredible hulk have a dog we
don't know about what if this dog gets
angry no no no no no no that just
doesn't exist
it doesn't exist
no baby it doesn't exist
[Music]
that just doesn't exist
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you